I had a series of visions when I was
younger
and after each one ended the same
thought would be stuck in my head what
you see I saw none
word of my visions reach the church and
I was asked to accompany a priest to an
abbey in Romania the Abbey has a long
history what Jacob down Koreans here
[Music]
[Music]
who's my girl my girl has love in her
heart and snow in her eyes and pepper in
her life every birthday kiddo this is
north I'm very sorry for your loss
we have three suspects in custody but
they're all linked to the Garcia cartel
no witnesses have been willing to step
up these cartels are no joke they've got
everyone net pockets you've been through
a terrible tragedy maybe you didn't see
what you think you saw did maybe you've
made a mistake
number three number five number four
[Music]
your recollection isn't what you thought
it was the evidence is insufficient to
hold the defendants over for trial you
think that you're gonna have justice
make them all all pay
five years ago Brian or just disappeared
completely off the grid so she spends
the last five years doing what training
well that's new he honestly think Riley
North did this
today's the five-year anniversary of her
family's murder she's back
group judges dirty cops what I want
incidents that makes this area low crime
it is low crime because apart maybe
somebody's doing something find her I
don't care if you have to burn this city
down watching someone take everything
from you it turns you into somebody else
social media is lit up with support for
she's a multiple homicide suspect now
gone now pretty much winging it from
there
do you know what my job description is
I'm in acquisitions I look up and I
catch what falls out of the sky
[Music]
tell me about the mission did you see
anything unusual it's above our pay
grade
[Music]
look I get it
something went down in Mexico nobody
wants any witnesses we need to know if
you and you man pose a threat
we're Rangers it Baxley if your mom's
vagina were a video game they'd be rated
E for Everyone there's an opposing the
three kind of the [ __ ] point
predators just don't sit around making
hats out of rib cages the conquered
space but that's not what's on the
horizon should I be worried
Riley I think you know what is on the
ship the ultimate predators we may die
we're still here
so come and get us [ __ ]
a few weeks ago I met Emily this
wonderful elegant person our son has
brought us together actually I think
you're joking but every time we do this
I feel so high Joan won't rate
confessions one that's a lot less thing
you've ever done
she is an enigma my life you can get
close to her can't quite reach oh she's
like a beautiful crushed you just take
my picture erase it I guess I'm probably
not the kind of person you're normally
friends with oh you do not want to be
friends with me trust me
Stephanie I need your help
are you okay I'm fine but I do need just
a simple favor can you call yeah
[Music]
five days ago Emily went missing
[Music]
I warn you you go poking around in her
past you're gonna find something that is
terrifying she was not a normal person
like you or me I've never seen such a
beautiful girl want to be so invisible
no perfume like a ghost it's just you
being paranoid
[Music]
she told me she hired Stephanie
[Music]
were you aware that he took out an extra
four million dollar life insurance
policy on Emily before she disappeared
people do terrible things for their own
reasons I thought you knew more than you
were letting off
I'm a secret how can we state that and
Detroit Sun lion don't leave us and
again I beside it's gonna be our year I
think Billy you realize you don't were
spot ever
I'm not gonna let you ruin your life Don
no drugs in house
everything's fine not fine fine miles by
nearby let her talk stay out of it
put some clothes on will ya we're going
for custard
[Music]
y'all know who my dad is right y'all
know what he saw I know your broke-ass
daddy put you said your name was
Brett hey white boy Rick you got some
balls coming here like you did you
should come out of scanner Oh sometimes
we're not like this but like you robbed
the Kmart or something you're good Rick
you want to move wait you come to me my
dad finds this you'll kick my ass just
make sure he doesn't find it then break
it down the dawn rocks
get yourself a pool and offload it
before long people hugging the gym
you're gonna get in too deep man they're
gonna challenge 14 ounces such a wave
you were born first time I looked in
your eyes I knew you were gonna be a big
[ __ ] and then your life was gonna be
bigger than mine look at this dad look
how we're living let's hustle big I know
the players man I know the game
hey come on dad I can do this we can do
this we can fix our lives and be a
family again
what do you say
ask yourself this would you believe a
fifteen-year-old kid was working for the
federal government but it was you all
got him last stop
Louis I'm your uncle Jonathan are you
wearing a robe it's a kimono here we are
home sweet home
you're Luis I presume how was your trip
this old hag is my neighbor I'm relieved
to see you didn't inherit your uncle's
freakishly oversized head my god did
that withered purple skeleton just speak
you'll see it's quite different here
have a look around you're perfectly safe
that's safe as long as it's fed do you
know what a warlock is Lois a boy which
I think they're a little more than boy
widgets are you seeing that you're a
warlock
please teach me please please okay have
it your way
I can give you the right books teach you
the right spells but that last 1% that's
up to you
I don't want the creepy little runt sink
I wanted lucky shot
you've told Lewis everything not
everything
this house used to be owned by another
warlock
he's very wicked very powerful he left a
hidden clock in the walls we don't know
what it does except something horrible
three gums last time it was for what
happens when it gets down to one nothing
good that's for certain
we have to destroy the clock
so creepy you can't do this alone I can
help you
one sees real magic I'll show you
shall we gahi pumpkins
Oh Teddy Walker what brings you back to
Piedmont I'm glad you asked
right now I have an amazing job in sales
but I'm here now to get my GED you would
have to go to night school you're in my
house are you doing the black voice no I
don't hear color you're the night school
teacher no I'm just the [ __ ] that like
to wear blouses yes I'm the night school
teacher let's do some introductions hey
yo what up I'm Bobby we can Skype into
the class yeah if you're doing time at
the Georgia Correctional Facility you're
next names Jalen how about you ma'am I
dropped out of high school
so I wanted to get my GED before they
have to live in Randy's parents laundry
room my name is Luis I'm going to become
a singer-songwriter no not like Julio
Iglesias oh it's gonna be a long
semester that's what's up
she's not like the teacher that we had
back in the day this woman is a brick
wall
school policy if you don't pass that
test you're out
once those tests really why don't you
wear black on laundry day so you wore
yellow it's fresh it's clean
you are my face what's it look like I'm
doing you gonna take my car my baby in
the backseat Oh baby in there Wayne
Wayne petty Luciano is Dermott a time
where I'm supposed to be at a fast food
playing next foot strip club I stand in
the right spot I smell cocoa butter and
fried chicken at the same time I need
you to go out there and I need you to
stop you know I can't flirt and my dad
was innocent now it's all about the bots
I heard a guys ain't gonna crack that
book like a walnut
did you start there wouldn't you want to
start in the front to stop
there's dances for students only get out
my way being shirt
thank you [ __ ] myself please please
continue with the Pythagorean theorem
the issue is you're clinically done I
knew it
there's no cure for what you have oh my
god I got learning Arby's there's no
such thing as learning herpes ah you
must Muslim we I'm sorry what what's
going okay why were you in ring with the
square root of 81 what what's the square
root of 81 I don't know welcome to your
castles in the air fill them wisely
loves Marmee I Amy March hi Margaret
March i Elizabeth March I Jo March
it will be a very successful writer and
do all the things a rich and famous
painter you don't know what it's like to
have everyone else make fun of your nose
will have a family of my own I'm gonna
make friends and go to parties and talk
to guys our own age I think this is my
castle just being here with all of you
so you're the infamous Lawrence grandson
Florence I wish to propose a new member
to the club every club needs a secret
mailbox welcome to The Pickwick Club
joke goodbye
but you are far more interesting than
what you write that's definitely a pass
for me pass for me as well me too
sweetie don't think I can compete for
the best writer I know I think it's
about growth and accepting change why do
you even want to get married because I
love him
growing up if to do with that
we go through all these stages of
learning and shifting and changing we
become something far from perfect but
perfectly unique the longer it takes for
you to forgive her longer your pain and
lasts we each have our own path to our
tassels
what's the most important piece of
workings of your mind
if you the cleanest current I'd rather
whose every word I ever wrote than lose
you
Oh missed my little one you're my person
I guess bro Marmee has dad thank you
[Music]
always cook each other reach our castles
no matter where they may be
I think that Chris I should still fall
in love with the prince it's not a love
story isn't everything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh Matt oh my god you're here
it's Halloween I got us VIP passes help
us what is best is a traveling horror
night has horror mazes it as well we
would totally lose in there
it's gonna be fun why are you signing a
waiver because the liability is pitch a
couple years ago some girl got totally
fed in killer left her body in the park
for three days they thought she was a
frickin problem some people are just
evil they walk amongst do you think
you're scaring me no move
[Music]
the more scared you seem then where they
gonna come after you you have to play it
cool
how's insane right yeah really
[Applause]
let's been following up the entire night
take your job too seriously
this really isn't funny
[Applause]
I came here to be scared right I can't
arrest people for doing their job
welcome to Hellfest
hello
hey can you let me out here
[Music]
welcome to the secret headquarters of we
have searched the entire mountain and
that day has finally arrived on the win
over the calm down you know how you get
it can't be true
MIGO you will be banished from the
village until you are ready to tell us
the truth is it too late to have second
thoughts if you die can I have all your
worldly possessions leading right sorry
when you die let's do this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
either first it's the Hajj taking you
home
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're gonna be safe here nice and warm
oh wait a minute what's how's that nice
and toasty all the way around hey what's
wrong
you hungry I found your food
[Music]
you